changhie for has gone where no
spacecraft has gone before the far side
of the moon the side hidden from Earth
images released on Chinese state
television showed the robotic Lander
descending towards the 1500 mile wide
von-karman crater near the Lunar South
Pole and is sent back the first picture
of its new home it's a technological
leap for the Chinese direct
communication to the far side is
impossible because signals would be
blocked by the bulk of the moon so they
had to place a satellite in a particular
orbit to relay instructions and send
back the data now starts the science the
lunar Explorer touched down on a side of
the moon we never see because it rotates
at the same speed that it orbits the
earth
changhie 4 and his robotic rover is in
the largest crater on the moon's surface
a nine mile deep scar from an ancient
impact that punched through the lunar
crust analyzing normal inaccessible
rocks for unusual minerals will be a
priority what you might expect is that
we we get a sort of look at the lunar
interior now it's a lunar interior that
it's been exposed to space for billions
of years so it isn't gonna be pristine
in that sense but nonetheless it
probably will be very different to the
stuff we've seen already from the
missions that went to the nearside
including the Apollo program so for that
alone it's a completely different
landscape the Chinese mission is
significant for its geopolitics
to the United States and Russia have
dominated space for decades but China is
becoming ever more confident about its
technology and wants a strategic
presence on the celestial stage if the
mission finds rich deposits of minerals
that are rare on earth it could make
lunar mining far more attractive and
fifty years after the Americans landed
on the moon this mission is also about
preparing the way for Chinese tycoon
Ott's to explore the surface and perhaps
even establish a base there which could
act as a refueling station to take on
water and the oxygen you can make from
it for the long journey to Mars